just about four and a half minutes away
from liftoff
the vehicle is healthy and we're
currently working no issues
the range is ready to support and as for
weather we can see that it's a beautiful
blue sky
position
the te is also what routes power fluids
and communication to both the rocket and
the satellite
the transporter erector has the launch
mount uh and that's what the first stage
is attached to uh and the strong back
that is hinged to the launch mount
and if you listen closely you can hear
the hissing and popping of pressure
venting from the rocket and the plumbing
in the transporter erector
as i mentioned before lox load is
underway for both the first and second
stages
rp1 loading is complete on both stages
and it looks like lox load on the first
stage just finished up
vehicle remains in good health
the gaseous oxygen
that you can start to see around the
vehicle venting from the base of falcon
9 that's from the chillin of the merlin
turbo pumps that occurred at t minus
seven minutes
one minute before liftoff you'll hear
the announcement that falcon 9 is in
startup which means that the rocket's
own internal computers are now
autonomously controlling the launch
countdown
as i mentioned before our
satellites are they're inside the
fairing they continue to be healthy team
is tracking no issues on the rocket
and as a reminder if we don't launch
today we do have a backup opportunity
tomorrow at the same time
and we have just two minutes to go
before launch
at this point in time locks load on the
second stage has just completed
and we can see the
white gaseous clouds around the vehicle
um as like i said lox load is complete
on second stage as well as first stage
so those lines
uh will be venting
from the t e
[Music]
the next milestone we're coming up to is
startup you'll hear the call out for
that at t minus one minute
that's the indication that the flight
computer has taken over
all right there's that call out falcon 9
is in startup at this point in time
stage one and stage two are beginning to
pressurize for launch
ld go for launch
and there was our final go for launch
today from our launch director
at this point in time as we approach t
minus 30 seconds all systems are go four
lines
let's listen in to the final countdown
t-minus 15 seconds
10
9
8
seven
six
five
four
three
two
one
zero ignition
and lift off
vehicles pitching downrange
phenomenal
all right as you can see falcon 9 has
cleared the tower lifted off from
cape canaveral space force station
we just heard the call out that the
vehicle is supersonic
currently
going to throttle down the engines in
preparation for max-q coming out
there we heard it so that was the moment
of greatest aerodynamic pressure that
the vehicle will experience in flight
today
everything looking nominal with stage
one trajectory
now we have five events coming up in
quick succession
miko or main engine cutoff stage
separation
stage one flip
second engine start one
and the boost back burn you can follow
along with those events there at the on
the timeline at the bottom of your
screen
beautiful view of the
code of the florida coastline
managing cutoff coming up in just under
30 seconds
as i mentioned before we will be landing
attempting to land the booster back on
land at landing zone one
this is known as return to launch site
as opposed to
a drone ship landing
eco
stage separation confirmed
[Music]
so you can see there
on the right hand side of your screen
second stage mvac engine has ignited the
first stage on the left hand side
is performing the boost back
uh which as you saw just moments ago
the first stage flipped itself over and
is now making its way back to the coast
of florida
everything looking nominal with second
stage trajectory there on the right hand
side of your screen
all right so there we heard the call out
that the boost back burn has concluded
that was the first of three burns that
the first stage will perform today and
we can see the grid fins beginning to
deploy
there on the left hand side of your
screen
the next event we have coming up
is fairing deployment
all right there you can see the two
fairing halves have separated fallen
away from the vehicle exposing the 105
spacecraft to the vacuum of space
as a reminder we will be attempting to
recover these brand new fairing halves
once they make their way back to earth
we're currently in the first of two mvac
burns this first one will last until
eight plus eight minutes and twenty t
plus eight minutes and 26 seconds
about another four minutes from now
beautiful views from the first stage
there on the left hand side of your
screen
and the second stage on the right
the next milestone will be the first
stage booster re-entry burn
falcon 9 executes an entry burn to slow
itself down before hitting the dense
part of the atmosphere
without this burn relying on the
atmosphere alone to slow down the falcon
9 would put
unnecessary strain on the rocket
and there we can see the east coast of
florida
on the nominal trajectory
space coast there in the background of
um on the left-hand side
once again we are
launching the transporter 3 mission
today
this is spacex's third dedicated small
sat rideshare program mission
and it's our second mission of 2022.
spacex is targeting at least three
dedicated ride share flights to sun
synchronous orbit per year and we also
offer opportunities for a ride to orbit
on our starlink missions which launch
every couple of weeks
small stats can ride to space on
spacex's falcon 9 falcon heavy as well
as starship in the not too distant
future
on the left-hand side of your screen we
can see those grid fins
have deployed falcon 9 has four
hypersonic grid fins positioned at the
base of the inner stage
and they orient the rocket during
re-entry by moving the center of
pressure
we can also see some white puffs of gas
coming off from falcon 9 those are cold
nitrogen gas
which help with attitude control
after first stage landing the second
stage will cut off its mvac engine and
re-light it approximately 45 minutes
later for deployment of all 105
spacecraft
as for first stage its next event is the
entry burn
stage two fts has saved
stage one entry burn startup
and there on your screen we can see that
that entry burn has begun
once again this burn is designed to slow
the booster down as it returns through
the dense part of the atmosphere
stage two on nominal trajectory
as we just heard there's one
shutdown everything continuing to look
good with second stage
as i mentioned earlier we will be
attempting to recover this booster for
the tenth time today and we're targeting
a land landing uh at landing zone one
the first stage has just one more burn
left the landing burn
it begins just before touchdown and
provides the booster a soft descent
before landing
about the same time that falcon lands we
are expecting seco or second engine cut
off uh one of our second stage
just a few seconds away from landing one
is transonic
vehicles traveling around 900 miles per
hour
really puts the deceleration into
perspective the span of less than a
minute we'll have reduced from twice
this twice the speed of injection
all the way down to zero as the rocket
lands
there's a view on the right-hand side
stage two and terminal guidance
of the landing page
as you heard from the call out there and
from the cheers behind me uh we have
successfully landed this falcon 9 for
the 10th time
it's also the 102nd recovery of an
orbital class
rocket nominal parking orbit
all right so we just heard their second
stage uh had a good orbit so we cut off
the or shut down the mvac engine on the
second stage and as we just heard it we
had a good orbit so we're now going to
coast for the next 45 minutes or so
while we wait for second engine start 2
or ses 2.
we'll see you back here at around t plus
55 minutes
[Music]
inspector now escape
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
mmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bye